en l'espace de deux mois google la
licence est successivement timide
debroux puis dernièrement margaret
mitchell
les deux codirectrices de son équipe des
tic désir la plus grande entreprise du
monde celle qui contrôle le plus le flux
de l'information qui surveille le plus
grand nombre d'adressés emails via
notamment gmail cette entreprise qui
conçoit les ja les plus sophistiqués qui
ait jamais existé
cette entreprise a littéralement
démanteler sa propre éthique mais le
pire dans tout cela à mon sens ce qui me
rend vraiment très pessimiste c'est que
j'ai l'horrible l'impression que tout le
monde s'en fout par sa jante un cas à
part les gens qui ont suivi la sphère de
très près new suite de twitter a
complètement ignoré le licenciement de
margaret mitchell et 24 heures après les
premiers articles anglophone la
couverture médiatique francophone est
resté ridiculement superficielle est
complètement absente des grands médias
même si le choix stratégique de google
licenciés margaret mitchell vendredi
soir ils sont pas étrangers pourtant la
situation me semble terrifiante
absolument terrifiante et cause la plus
probable de ces deux licenciements est
un article accepter la publication à la
conférence académique fact ton petit
milieu bros et margaret mitchell était
co trice cet article désormais
accessibles en ligne discute très
raisonnablement des risques liés aux ia
entraîné sur d'énormes quantités de
données téléchargées sur internet comme
c'est le cas de gpt 3 développé par aux
pénuries dont l'étrave est raciste sont
largement avérés et comme c'est aussi le
cas des bien plus énorme modèle
développé par google
une partie dédiée à de google a été
récemment rendus publics en janvier 2021
et on y apprend que google a conçu unis
à dix fois plus grosse que toutes les
îles précédente avec des bases de
données toujours plus grosse est
toujours moins sécurisés google semble
s'embarquer dans une course à lire sans
doute en réaction aux annonces
dithyrambique d'open et ac ou à une
menace perçue venant des entreprises
chinoises par exemple
or cette course à la performance ne
paraît extrêmement dangereuse voire
complètement terrifiante
oui parce que pour avoir des super
performance il faut des énormes
algorithmes et pour avoir des énormes
algorithmes il faut des données car
quand tu es sq et google semble
justement actuellement faire ingurgiter
toutes sortes de données à saisir sans
trop se soucier de la qualité de ses
données
or si vous entraînez vos vies avec des
données collectées sur reddit
alors il faut vous attendre à ce que
tous les messages horrible partagés sur
edit
répétez pas ressaisir pire encore on se
rend compte que saisir memories beaucoup
de ce qu'alice un peu comme les humains
or les ja le plus sophistiqué de google
apprennent probablement de vos emails
autrement dit si google déploie ses
algorithmes de manière précipitée sans
aucun audit interne ou externe ce qui
est vers quoi on se dirige alors il
n'est pas impossible que lorsqu'on
cherche sur google une question
personnelle sur vous google nous
fournissent une réponse fondée sur la
lecture de vos emails
alors on en n'est peut-être pas encore
là le gros problème c'est qu'on ne peut
pas savoir où on en est vraiment car
google garde ses algorithmes ultrasecret
la version ainsi publié n'est sans doute
que la face immergée de l'iceberg
les algorithmes les plus sophistiqués de
l'entreprise ceux qui ont résulté de
centaines de millions de dollars
d'investissement ces algorithmes sont
encore secrets est impossible à auditer
y compris pour la quasi totalité des
employés de google dont les droits
d'accès sont très limitées et même la
version publiée née des critiques que de
manière très superficielle dans
l'article de recharge et avec un focus
sur des aspects techniques uniquement
pire encore les rares voix en interne
qui ont osé questionner la quête de
performance de google se sont fait
malmenés puis le licencier google a
d'ailleurs aussi exigé la rétraction
d'autres articles questionnant par
exemple l'éthique des algorithmes de
recommandation
finalement cet article a été acceptée
dans une world cup un email mais ses
auteurs de google ont été supprimés de
la liste des auteurs
le message est ainsi clair pour tous
ceux qui oseraient a soulevé des
préoccupations éthiques en interne
au mieux vous ne serez jamais reconnu
publiquement pour vos travaux au pire
comme dans le cas de jimmy kébreau de
margaret mitchell et peut-être bientôt
de toute l'équipe des tic désir google
votre carrière et votre réputation
risque d'être traînée dans la boue alors
que vous serez mis sous pression
caricaturer et diaboliser le contraste
avec le monde de l'aviation par exemple
est particulièrement saisissant les
crashs des boeing 737 max on causait 3
146 morts en l'espace de cinq mois ces
crash ont fait la une de l'actualité
encore et encore ils ont forcé la
suspension de vols de ce modèle de
boeing et ils ont conduit un audit
approfondi des avions pendant un an et
demi par les autorités de certification
mais pendant ces mêmes cinq mois on peut
estimer que les centaines de millions de
recommandations douteuses sur des sujets
comme la vaccination ou les cancers ont
pu causer indirectement des centaines de
milliers de morts en propageant des
informations dangereux sur des échelles
gargantuesque les ja du web durait alors
100 à 1000 fois plus que les avions
d'effectuer de boeing dans leurs pires
périodes et tout ça c'est sans même
compter sur les problèmes de
radicalisation dont on a vu les
conséquences spectaculaires et
terrifiante lors des émeutes du capitole
vous alors que les avions subissent les
audits externes prolongée et extrêmement
coûteux pour l'entreprise
on est en train de donner carte blanche
à google pour licencier les rares
personnes à même de questionner les tic
désir de google bref google est en train
de créer les conditions parfaites pour
des déploiements précipité d'algorithmes
ultra dangereux qui pourrait alimenter
toujours plus les théories du complot
les mets informations médicales
la manipulation politique l'addiction à
ces produits les bières assiste dans ses
résultats de recherche et la révélation
indirects d'informations personnelles
et pourtant tout le monde s'en fout 6 2
% des employés de google ont protesté le
licenciement de timides gros on en est à
moins de 0,1 pour cent dans l'industrie
de la tech
en effet il ya quatre mille signataires
externe et selon ces chiffres
il y aurait 12 millions d'employés dans
la tech si on se restreint uniquement
aux états unis même dans le monde
académique
la fraction des gens qui se préoccupent
activement de ses déviances terrifiante
de google est ridiculement faible
puisque à travers le monde
il ya sans doute autour de 1 million
d'étudiants et de chercheurs en
informatique l'entreprise dont les
algorithmes contrôle plus que quiconque
quelles informations seront communiquées
à quel utilisateur
cette entreprise est en train de chez
sur l'éthique et tout le monde s'en fout
et comme tout le monde s'en fout des
propositions d'amendements visant à
permettre l'audit externe des
algorithmes privé comme celle d'adrien
fabry de guillaume chazot à la députée
paule à forte à n'ont pas été retenus si
on ne donne pas davantage d'importance à
l'éthique des algorithmes des
entreprises du numérique
il n'y aura pas de magie faute de
pression sociale ou légal google va sans
doute persiste et a préféré la
performance à l'éthique à démanteler
toute unité en interne qui oserait
mettre des bâtons dans les roues à la
sacro-sainte course à la performance et
à déployer des algorithmes dangereux que
personne n'aura et ne pourra audit est
aujourd'hui la meilleure façon de réagir
et sans doute aidé des plus de perdre
apprendre davantage la mesure de
l'ampleur du problème des algues au
rythme de recommandations et de la
gravité des décisions de google et vous
pouvez y contribuer en partageant cette
vidéo on en parle en autour de vous et
en vous informant davantage sur le sujet
par exemple avec notre livre le fabuleux
chantier dont mon co auteur al mahdi el
mhamdi s'est malencontreusement
retrouvée au coeur de cette affaire
maddie a rejoint google pourrait y en
octobre dernier et son manager n'était
autre que timide que bros et cantines il
que vos s'est fait licencier il s'est
retrouvé sous les ordres de margaret
mitchell
or sur twitter elle m'a dit ainsi que la
demi douzaine de chercheurs qui
composent équipe le titre de liga chez
google où tous témoigné en faveur de
leur manager licenciés malgré le risque
qu'il y avait sur leur carrière
professionnelle
et ça ça augmente radicalement macrez
dansant la version des faits proposés
par timmy globaux et margaret mitchell
et donc mes préoccupations vis-à-vis de
la gestion de l'éthique par google bref
je vous supplie de réfléchir à comment
vous pourriez contribué à l'éthique des
algorithmes réfléchissent et notamment
aux personnes dans votre entourage qui
pourrait beaucoup gagné à voir cette
vidéo parce qu'ils sont dans l'industrie
de la tech travaillent dans les médias
ou sont proches de la politique qui on
va avoir une chance d'arrêter google
dans sa démolition de l'éthique au
profit de la course
à lire il va nous falloir surveiller
avec beaucoup plus d'attention tout ce
que google fait